welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul
aka the cobra guy who this week has
showed you how to milk a snake
and we're back with another video on the
karate kids spin-off
season three debuted roughly this time
last week and it offered a glimmer of
hope for the start of 2021
before we inevitably return to the dark
ages the series ended on a big
cliffhanger
and throughout this video we're going to
be breaking down everything we know
about season 4 so far
there will be heavy spoilers here in
regards to the events of season 3
so if you haven't had a chance to check
it out then bye yeah
if that joke hasn't ruined your day then
please click the thumbs up button
and make sure you subscribe for
breakdowns like this throughout the week
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into cobra kai
okay so people who are worried that the
fourth season may be the last
need fear not the creative team behind
this series have recently revealed that
they planned
all the way up to season six this isn't
the end either and producer josh yield
has revealed that
though they have an ending in mind that
it won't be happening anytime
soon yay more cobra kai videos to milk
now things are gonna ramp up even more
and the series will likely get bigger
and better
he'll reveal that they're gonna slowly
start bringing things together
and putting certain aspects in place to
ramp up to a crazy finale
when discussing this the producer said
we have an end game in our heads
we've had one for quite some time and
it's not in season four
it's well beyond that in our minds we
have seasons worth of story
that is necessary to tell before we get
to that end game
that will be a discussion going forward
with our new partners at netflix
can we write to that endgame can we know
that it's coming
that's not always the case with
television and we respect that
for now we're continuing to write at the
same speed and with the same path that
we set out from the beginning
so end game yeah kris is thanos
confirmed
now though this isn't strictly season
four news it's clear that they're
putting plans in place to build towards
it
and as far as four is concerned there
are a lot of things to look forward to
the script for the season was actually
finished late last year
and filming for the show is due to take
place between january and april of this
one
though we don't have a specific release
day just yet for the project
due to the seasons mainly being 10 half
hour episodes with little to no cgi
i would imagine that it's actually
possible that we get the trailer
or the season itself before the end of
the year this was actually teased at by
john hurwitz who stated that it would
come out roughly a year after the
release of season three
now because of kovid there will be
strict protocols in place for filming
the project
and as we've seen with other things such
as the batman these can lead to
shutdowns if broken
however i have faith that mr miyagi is
looking over us all
and that the project will stay on course
to give us something to send the air off
in style to
or start next year in style but you know
what i mean
now as we saw with season three it
actually ended up airing a week earlier
than planned
so there is potential that they bring
things forward if they have the ability
to
now as for the main cast we do know that
all the main players such as
danny johnny crease sam miguel
and johnny will be returning there's
also going to be dimitri
hawk and potentially the return of terry
silva at the end of season 3 it did seem
like crease was calling him
and though we don't know if we're
definite i'd put all the silver i have
a on him being the big bad in an
interview with entertainment weekly
john hewitt said the following when
talking about his return
at the end of the season you saw chris
make a phone call
you could guess who might have been on
the other end of that call based off of
the photo that he was looking at
but we can't really speak to how terry
silva would respond to that call
or or or whoever was on the other end of
the line
would respond to that call i think
you'll have to see if that character
returns
so bit of a slip there mate bit of a
slip letting us know that it was terry
silva
but i'll let you off and at the moment
thomas ian griffith
hasn't confirmed whether he will be back
or not now one of the bigger missions in
season three
was of course aisha she was pretty much
a staple of season one and two
but the character disappeared faster
than robbie's mullet
is it a mullet not really but but stick
with me it was said that after the fight
at the end of season two that she was
moved to a private school
and i'm guessing that stingray must have
went with her and got a job as a
security guard
though these absences were felt
massively in season three
there is a possibility that the
character could return and in an
interview with tv line
john herwitz said the following we love
aisha and we love nicole brown
just because a character doesn't appear
for a period of time
doesn't mean they have left the universe
that they can't return again
this of course happened in the case of
the bullies who are in season one
not in two and then pop back up for
season three so it is possible that
aisha could come back at some point
i just feel bad for her as she lost
loads of weight and then got cut
but the these cobra kai kids yeah they
show no mercy
now speaking of people that lost weight
did anyone notice danny's son
showed up looking like a gymspiration
post at one point in the season
i kind of feel like he might end up
getting but as part of the larger roster
and if dany taught sam the ways of
karate it makes sense that he would do
the same for his own son
crease could easily recruit new people
too so the door is definitely open to
see new and old faces joining the cast
kind of feel like because of the end
game comment that the creative team
are gonna be going back to all the
karate kid properties and picking the
most recognizable people from that
there's of course many characters from
the karate kid chosen
the next karate kid with hillary swank
and ali could even come back for the
finale
you really have the opportunity here to
dig deep into the law
and bring forth numerous people from the
past to stand off against crease and
silver
there's also the potential for mike
barnes's return and if it's all gonna
ramp up to be a big end game event
it's inevitable hey that a lot of cast
members will come back
now at the end of the season we of
course saw johnny and daniel
truly joining forces and this is
something that fans have wanted for a
long time
when discussing this moment with tv line
josh shield said
giving them this moment was something
we've always known was coming
but we're doing it in a way where we've
also established who these characters
are
they're both very strong-minded in their
own philosophies ideals and pasts
there does appear to be a very distinct
battle ahead a very clear boundary and
set of circumstances that have brought
them to this moment
but time will tell if history repeats
itself and they fall back into old
habits again
so even if jonny and danny do win there
is a possibility that things split once
more
and the pair are put back into a sort of
civil war scenario before things climax
the key person in all of this has always
been robbie and a lot of the seasons
have been a battle for the soul of the
character
when he first came on the scene he was a
bit of a bad boy
but he did turn good after dany took him
under his wing
he started to fall for sam and really
seemed to be the polar opposite of his
old self
however he viewed her as betraying him
for miguel and when both
johnny and dany had a hand in having him
arrested the only thing that made sense
was for him to turn back to the dark
side
season three culminated in him joining
cobra kai and herwitz had a lot to say
on this matter
robbie is somebody who has a deep
history with johnny
and he now has a deep history with
daniel in season three you see him on
this roller coaster journey
figuring out how to deal with the
aftermath of what happened with miguel
and figuring out who to trust and who's
truly there for him
you see how season three ends and he's
there with crease
so in season four we'll have to see does
he go full kobakai
does he embrace the quote-unquote dark
side in every way
or do the lessons of his past have an
impact as well
so season 4 certainly has a strong
journey for the robbie character
so yeah that sounds really good and for
the moment that's everything we know
about the upcoming season
i'll of course keep you informed on
what's happening but in the meantime i'd
love to hear your thoughts and what you
want to see
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll also be entered into a
prize draw where we're giving away three
copies of the hobbit and lord of the
rings 4k box set to our subscribers
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the season
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now
so if that's you then message me on
twitter at
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the best cobra kai season 4 theories
which will be linked on screen right now
we give our thoughts on where things
could be going so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want something else
to watch
without the way thank you for sitting
through the video i've been paul i see
you next time
take care peace